der korona schuldenberg wächst das
bundeskabinett billigt für das kommende
jahr neue kredite von fast 100
milliarden euro
juristisches nachspiel ischgl urlauber
klagen gegen österreich weil in dem
ski-ort zu spät auf corona reagiert
worden sei leiden unter hitze und dürre
woanders riesige landstriche unter
wasser
experten debattieren in hamburg über die
zunahme extremer wetterereignisse
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten norbert lehmann
ist auch da er hat den sport wenn ein
kunde von mir auch im nächsten jahr wird
uns die korona krise viel geld kosten
die schulden werden weiter wachsen
von einer historischen ausnahmesituation
spricht denn auch finanzminister scholz
von der schwarzen null ist nicht mehr
die rede
das kabinett hat seinen haushaltsentwurf
heute gebilligt schauen wir uns die
zahlen an
für 2021 plant der bundesfinanzminister
mit neuen schulden in höhe von gut 96
milliarden euro eine gewaltige summe
noch gewaltiger ist die im laufenden
jahr
hier gibt es eine rekord neuverschuldung
von etwa 218 milliarden euro
die details jetzt von andreas künast die
zahlen die olaf scholz unterm arm hat am
morgen im kanzleramt sind so
außergewöhnlich hoch dass dieser
haushalt noch folgen für viele haushalte
der zukunft haben wird wegen der
beispiellosen corona rettungs und
konjunkturpakete sind nächstes jahr
ausgaben von 413 milliarden euro geplant
nach 508 milliarden euro in diesem das
ist sehr sehr viel geld das wir nötig
haben um dazu beizutragen dass die
konjunktur stabilisiert wird aber es ist
auch genau richtig nachdem die
neuverschuldung nach den jahren der
schwarzen null in diesem jahr auf den
höchsten wert der nachkriegsgeschichte
steigt rechnet die regierung im nächsten
mit dem zweithöchsten mit 96 milliarden
euro die große koalition und ich bin
hier sehr enttäuscht von der cdu csu
muss irgendwann mal kapieren dass man
die viertgrößte marktwirtschaft der welt
nicht auf dauer auf pump finanzieren
kann
da hätten zeichen kommen müssen all
diese zeichen für die zukunft fehlen
noch geht scholz rechnungen für die
nächsten jahre nicht auf in seiner
planung klafft ein loch 40 milliarden
euro groß
spricht alles dafür dass wir erneut das
hinbekommen können was uns schon einmal
gelungen ist nämlich dass die
wirklichkeit besser verläuft als die
rechnung so war das nach der letzten
finanzkrise
olaf scholz hat keine idee präsentiert
wie er diese löcher in zukunft stopfen
will
ich nenne das arbeitsverweigerung ergibt
diese probleme einfach der nächsten
regierung vor die füße und die gefahr
ist dass ein großer spardruck in den
nächsten haushalten kommen wird schon in
zwei jahren will olaf scholz die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten
steuersenkungen schließt der
finanzminister aus steuererhöhungen
nicht mehr hilfskräfte für die pflege
und mehr geld für die krankenkassen
beides hat das bundeskabinett heute auch
auf den weg gebracht konkret sollen die
pflegeheime in deutschland 20.000
pflegeassistenz stellen bekommen und für
die kassen gibt es wegen corona nächstes
jahr einen zusätzlichen bundeszuschuss
von fünf milliarden euro und auch der
klimaschutz stand auf der tagesordnung
da will das kabinett den ausbau des
ökostroms beschleunigen und dafür dass
ein neuer erneuerbare-energien-gesetz
reformieren das ziel bleibt bis 2030
mindestens 65 prozent des
stromverbrauchs klimaneutral abzudecken
2050 dann 100 prozent dafür aber sollen
wind und solaranlagen schneller
ausgebaut werden und damit diese auch
wirklich passiert soll auch schärfer
kontrolliert werden
seit 2005 10 seitdem weit mehr über eine
million menschen nach europa geflohen
sind hat die europäische union keine
gemeinsame linie in der flüchtlingsfrage
das zeigte sich gerade erst auch wieder
nach dem brand im flüchtlingslager moria
heute hat die eu kommission ihre pläne
für einen migrations packt vorgestellt
schnellere asylverfahren hilfen für
besonders betroffene länder wie
griechenland aber keine verteilungs
quote aus brüssel gunnar krüger moria
war nur der letzte weckruf die eu sucht
schon lange eine politik für asyl und
migration der vorschlag am mittag
deshalb
sache der chefin es gibt dabei nicht um
die frage ob mitgliedstaaten mit
solidarität und beiträgen unterstützen
sondern wie sie unterstützen statt auf
die umstrittene quote zur verteilung
setzt die kommission nun auf flexible
beiträge der mitgliedstaaten das wären
die aufnahme von asylberechtigten aber
auch hilfen bei der rückführung etwa mit
geld und beamten das sorgt für kritik
solidarität ist im klartext die einheit
als abschottung und abschiebe
gemeinschaft die osteuropäischen staaten
sondern mitwirken indem er menschen
zurück verfrachtet in die staaten aus
denen sie eingereist sind und selbst
diese solidarität wäre freiwillig nur in
krisen wie 2015 gilt ein verpflichtender
solidaritäts mechanismus was das heißt
verhandlungssache
deshalb möchte ich heute meine
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
mitgliedsstaaten appellieren jetzt nicht
reflexartig in die deckung zu gehen
wir wollen uns zunächst auf die punkte
konzentrieren bei denen alle
mitgliedsstaaten gemeinsamkeiten haben
unter deutschem vorsitz müssen die
innenminister nun den vorschlag beraten
und die frage klären was passiert wenn
alle nur abschieben und keine aufnehmen
leben ja anne gellinek in brüssel mit
dem neuen migrations beamten in brüssel
jetzt auf die länder rücksicht die
partout keine flüchtlinge haben wollen
könnte das denn nun funktionieren
die eu-kommission hat den
mitgliedsstaaten genau zugehört und hat
dabei vernommen dass es nicht nur die
osteuropäer sind die keine flüchtlinge
aufnehmen wollen sondern eben auch
länder im baltikum in skandinavien die
niederlande sogar frankreich zögert und
die folge dieses zuhörens ist dass der
vergiftete begriff der verpflichtenden
quote zur verteilung von flüchtlingen in
diesem vorschlag nicht mehr auftaucht
stattdessen stellt
kommission es den mitgliedstaaten frei
ob sie flüchtlinge aufnehmen wollen oder
ob sie abgelehnte asylbewerber
abschieben wollen
das wird in osteuropa mit genugtuung
aufgenommen werden die südeuropäer wird
es eher besorgen denn wenn sich
mitgliedstaaten durch abschiebe flüge
freikaufen können werden nimmt dann noch
migranten aus italien und griechenland
auf und die zweite frage ist dass die
anderen vorschläge mehr grenzschutz
schnellere asylverfahren effizientere
abschiebungen alle schon in den letzten
jahren schon mal so oder ähnlich da
waren und sie sind allesamt an der
umsetzung gescheitert
vielen dank an der geld aus brüssel die
vorschläge für eine neue
migrationspolitik was die eu jetzt im
einzelnen plant haben wir online noch
mal kurz und knapp zusammengefasst
jederzeit nachzulesen in der zdf- heute-
app gute nachrichten vom kreml kritiker
alexander wollen legen
er hat das krankenhaus in berlin
verlassen auf instagram postete der
44-jährige dieses foto mit hilfe von
physiotherapeuten und ärzten will er nun
wieder zu kräften kommen mehr als 30
tage musste navalny behandelt werden
zwischenzeitlich lag er im koma der
russische oppositionspolitiker war laut
bundesregierung mit einem nerven
kampfstoff der nordgruppe vergiftet
worden
corona in deutschland im märz stiegen
die fallzahlen schlagartig an
ein wesentlicher grund dafür das was
vorher in ischgl passiert war österreich
anfang märz in dem skiort in tirol
infizieren sich immer mehr menschen vor
allem in überfüllten après ski bars ab
mitte des monats gilt eine quarantäne
trotzdem können touristen ungehindert
abreisen und des virus verbreiten
6000 menschen aus 45 ländern haben sich
nach eigenen angaben dort angesteckt es
gab auch todesfälle
nun klagen betroffene gegen österreich
britta hilpert
im april starb rudi lempicka starb
ancona mitte märz hatte er sich in
ischgl angesteckt seine lebensgefährtin
ist überzeugt er könnte noch leben wenn
österreichs regierung besser reagiert
hätte ich bin einfach unglaublich
enttäuscht wütend von der regierung die
hätte viel früher reagieren müssen und
den ort zu machen müssen
sie klagt wie rund 1000 weitere opfer
heute reicht verbraucherschutz anwalt
peter kolba die ersten muster klagen ein
er meint die behörden hätten im april
skiort ischgl zu spät zu zaghaft und zu
chaotisch reagiert
ich gehörte in island schon anfang märz
als risikogebiet doch die landesbehörden
ließen weiter skifahren weiter feiern
auch als barpersonal positiv getestet
wurde
eine übertragung des corona virus auf
gäste der bar ist eher unwahrscheinlich
hieß es
erst fünf tage später verkündet kanzler
kurz quarantäne
diese gebiete werden ab sofort isoliert
fluchtartig verliessen daraufhin
touristen und ortsfremde mitarbeiter ist
die polizei aber hielt sie nicht in
quarantäne am ort sie damit nur ihre
daten
die wurden aber nie an andere länder zur
infektions nachverfolgung überstellt so
der anwalt
in tirol hat man vor ort schwere fehler
gemacht und in wien hat man zu gesehen
weder aus tirol noch aus wien haben
betroffene wie dörte sich bisher eine
entschuldigung gehört für sie ein grund
erst recht auf der klage zu bestehen in
berlin wurde heute eine erste bilanz in
sachen corona waren abgezogen wie
verbreitet ist sie und vor allem was
bringt sie im kampf gegen die pandemie
der ist nämlich noch lange nicht vorbei
im gegenteil waren virologen auch wenn
die zahl der neuinfektionen mit rund
1800 pro tag stabil ist im moment
christiane hübscher der
bundesaußenminister seit heute in
quarantäne
einer seiner personenschützer hat sich
mit corona infiziert ein erster test bei
heiko maas war negativ doch eine reise
nach jordanien muss er absagen
christian drosten sie deutschland
derweil nicht ausreichend auf herbst und
winter vorbereitet wir müssen um die
situation in den kommenden monaten zu
beherrschen dinge ändern so der virologe
die pandemie wird jetzt erst richtig
losgehen auch bei uns damit das
öffentliche leben so gut wie möglich
weiterlaufen könne fordert die
wissenschaftsakademie leopoldina von der
bundesregierung eine einheitliche
strategie
dazu gehören aber auch klare ansage
klare sind dann regeln und nicht so ein
bunter flickenteppich der
unterschiedlichsten länder weil es immer
mehr hotspots gibt erteilt das
kanzleramt alle lockerungsübungen von
ministerpräsidenten eine absage
mit einem diffusen infektionsgeschehen
ist momentan kein anlass dafür gegeben
über weitere lockerungen nachzudenken
sondern über klare beschränkung sprechen
damit sich das geschehen insgesamt in
deutschland weiter gut eindämmen lässt
helfen soll dabei auch die korona waren
es 18 millionen downloads aber zu wenige
nutzer die ihr positives testergebnis
auch eingeben
bitte nutzen sie dieses werkzeug in der
pandemie auch informieren sie die
kontakte und das ist wichtig die
kontakte werden nicht informiert wer sie
informiert gesundheitsämter aber klagen
sie bekommen zu viele anrufe von
verunsicherten nutzern die eine diffuse
warnmeldung von der app erhalten haben
wurden viele millionen reingesteckt es
werden auch noch weitere millionen
fließen aber sie hat in den letzten
hundert tagen nicht beweisen können dass
sie uns die arbeit in irgendeiner weise
erleichtert die schlechte nachricht auch
weiter er wird die app auf vielen
älteren smartphones nicht laufen können
tesla in grünheide für die einen die
chance auf fortschritte im
strukturschwachen brandenburg andere
sehen die so genannte giga factory als
gefahr für tiere pflanzen und wasser
während die fabrik schon gestalt annimmt
und tesla gerade angekündigt hat dass
dort nicht nur autos sondern auch
hochmoderne batteriezellen gebaut werden
sollen kamen heute die kritiker zu wort
nicola albrecht
so schnell wie derzeit tesla in
grünheide baut wird im raum
berlin-brandenburg selten gebaut viel zu
schnell mit inakzeptablen folgen für
natur infrastruktur und anwohner finden
bürgerinitiativen und umweltverbände
mehr als 100 ihrer vertreter sind heute
zur diskussion mit konzern und behörden
gekommen
uns geht es vor allem darum dass
wirklich die natur und umweltschutz
belange wirklich intensiver noch
beleuchtet werden wir lassen uns
jährlich über den tisch ziehen damit da
haben wir weiter große profite machen
kann
ihr ziel brandenburgs landesumweltamt
überzeugen tesla keine abschließende
baugenehmigung zu erteilen
die debatte im saal ist nicht öffentlich
journalisten können sie über einen
livestream verfolgen die stimmung
aufgeheizt es sei eine schein anhörung
der vorwurf wir können schon genau
einschätzen wo die zürich doing geht es
gibt hier da auch aussagen von der
politik tatsächlich bei tesla chef elon
musk in brandenburg derzeit nur mit
vorläufiger sondergenehmigung
doch er weiß für das land brandenburg
hat das größte private industrieprojekt
seit der wiedervereinigung höchste
priorität
es gibt schon eine reihe auch von
verbänden ihr auch gesagt haben also sie
sehen eigentlich nichts was wirklich als
killerargument dafür sozusagen im raum
steht und ich glaube dann darf man sich
trauen ganz vorsichtig zu sagen dass
eine große chance besteht dass wir das
genehmigungsverfahren im dezember
erfolgreich abschließen schon ab sommer
21 sollen die elektroautos in
brandenburg vom band laufen
40.000 arbeitsplätze verspricht sich die
landesregierung auf einen baustopp
können sie hier kaum hoffen aber auf
nachbesserungen in sachen umweltschutz
schon seit den chor ohne ausbrüchen in
der fleischindustrie stehen die
arbeitsbedingungen dort im fokus die
bundespolizei hat heute razzien in fünf
bundesländern durchgeführt der verdacht
illegale leiharbeit
die ermittler durchsuchten zahlreiche
wohn und geschäftsräume über einen
firmenkonstrukt sollen mehr als 80
osteuropäer mit falschen papieren
eingeschleust worden sein
laut bundespolizei gibt es zehn
hauptbeschuldigten
sommer 2020 wieder war es ein sehr
warmer und trockener
der temperaturanstieg in deutschland
beschleunigt sich hieß es heute auf dem
extremwetterkongress in hamburg schauen
wir auf die daten neun der zehn wärmsten
jahre seit beginn der aufzeichnungen
sind ab dem jahr 2000 aufgetreten
das sei nur durch menschen gemachte
erwärmung zu erklären sagen die experten
und deutschland muss sich auf längere
hitze phasen einstellen weil sich die
globalen windströmungen verändern
martin ließen im westen der usa brennen
wälder in historischem ausmaß
im süden und osten führen hurricanes zu
überflutungen
das arktische meereis ist auf die
zweitkleinste fläche seit beginn der
messungen geschrumpft und auch der
jetstream verändert sich die stark wind
ströme in der atmosphäre bekommen dellen
hoch und tiefdruckgebiete bewegen sich
langsam der klimawandel führt eben dazu
dass sich die globalen windsysteme
verändern und dadurch können tatsächlich
möglicherweise extreme wetterlagen
länger anhalten als es bisher der fall
gewesen ist
das hat darüber sind sich die experten
beim extremwetterkongress in hamburg
einig dramatische konsequenzen auch für
deutschland der dritte sommer in folge
mit langen trockenperioden und
hitzewellen hat vor allem im norden und
osten ernten und wälder zerstört im
süden dagegen häufen sich stark regen
und unwetter zu warm aber ist es überall
im land der temperaturanstieg liegt
deutlich über dem weltweiten
durchschnitt
wir haben einen anstieg von etwa 1,6
grad in deutschland im jahresmittel zu
verzeichnen dass es mehr als weltweit
wohl wie etwa bei 1,1 grad liegen
wir sehen aber auch veränderungen dass
das thema ja hier bei den extremen
stürme starke niederschläge trockenheit
hitze waldbrände
es wird mehr davon in deutschland geben
er war erst im osten des landes ein star
dann auch im westen der schauspieler und
regisseur michael kristic gestern ist er
im alter von 78 jahren gestorben
komödiant melancholiker oder exzentriker
seinen figuren gab kristek witz und
tiefe oft mit berliner schnauze
zu seinen bekanntesten filmen gehören
goodbye lenin boxhagener platz und
nachtgestalten für seine arbeit bekam er
auszeichnungen vom deutschen filmpreis
bis zum grimme preis und nun zum fußball
norbert morgen der uefa super cup
münchen gegen sevilla das erste spiel
der bayern vor publikum seit monaten
und dann ausgerechnet im corona
risikogebiet budapest bis zu 20.000
zuschauer im stadion darunter auch fcb
fans aus deutschland
das ziel der bayern nach dem triple nun
den vierten saison titel holen
das supercup-finale in der porsche arena
ist für die uefa und sogenannte pilot
test 20.000 dürfen morgen ins stadion
trotz der hohen infektionszahlen ich
lebe ja in münchen auch fassenden krone
hotspot von daher hat sich nicht allzu
viel geändert
nein es ist er sie so wir sind
hierhergekommen um fußball zu spielen
entscheidungen wenn woanders getroffen
die spieler werden weitestgehend von der
außenwelt abgeschirmt das problem sind
die fans die zb mit dem zug nach
budapest kommen
ihnen droht bei rückkehr eine 14-tägige
quarantäne
wir haben jegliches interesse daran dass
dort wirklich ich glaube der herr söder
auch gesagt keine stelle des fußballs
stattfindet und dann müssen die bayern
noch die gerüchte um eine rückkehr von
mario götze nach münchen aus der welt
schaffen ich hätte mario sehr weiß auch
wo er seine stärken hat und aktuell ist
für uns kein thema der ungarische
fußballverband teilt die übrigens mit
das stadion soll morgen der sicherste
ort im ganzen land die wege hin und
zurück allerdings sind es nur für die
mannschaften nicht für die auf den
rängen ja nochmal zu den bayern robert
lewandowski und manuel neuer sind für
die wahl zu europas fußballer des jahres
nominiert und münchens coach hansi flick
für die trainer auszeichnung der uefa
neben juliane zwang und jürgen klopp
tennisprofi yannick hansmann hat bei den
hamburger european open den einzug ins
viertelfinale verpasst
der 28 jährige karlsruher oben im bild
musste sich den argentinier cristian gar
ihn in zwei sätzen mit 2 6 und 6 7
geschlagen geben und schied als
vorletzter deutscher aus diesem turnier
aus mit dabei ist noch dominik koepfer
der spitze stunde im achtelfinale gegen
den spanier roberto bautista akut
schöner name wunderbar ausgesprochen
was fehlt noch zum schluss die
lottozahlen hier sind sie die
gewinnzahlen lauten 6 19 25 26 32 33 und
die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
jetzt wird es von tag zu tag
wechselhafter kühler und regnerischer
doch zwischendurch bleibt auch mal platz
für die sonne genauer sagt es ihnen
gleich katja hornuf das war es von uns
schön dass sie dabei waren
das heute journal mit claus kleber um 21
uhr 45 und morgen meldet sich an dieser
stelle um 19 uhr christian sievers mit
den nachrichten ihnen noch einen schönen
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren fast
eine woche lang war dieses hoch manfred
für den sonnigen und warmen spätsommer
verantwortlich jetzt aber pirscht sich
der herbst dran nämlich hier von
nordwesten kommen die regenwolken zu uns
an aber über die alpen ziehen auch
einige schauer und gewitter zu uns das
haben wir heute schon gemerkt in bayern
und in baden württemberg später dann
auch in sachsen die lassen jetzt mehr
und mehr nach dafür wird das wolkenband
westlich von uns interessant das bringt
nämlich regen mit und der zieht bis
morgen früh weiter in richtung kiel
kassel und stuttgart bevor der regen
ankommt kann sich an der donau noch mal
nebel bilden und danach wird es
stürmisch besonders an der nordsee
das wird eine milde nacht die
temperaturen sinken auf 16 bis 9 grad
und der regen der nacht sieht morgen
rasch aus deutschland ostwärts ab dann
ist es erstmal ganz freundlich bevor der
nachmittags hier von der schweiz neue
gewittrige regenfälle weiter nach
nordosten ziehen
für viele wird das also morgen ein ganz
freundlicher tag bei südwestwind und es
wird deutlich kühler als heute
die höchsttemperaturen liegen nur noch
zwischen 16 grad in der eifel und bis zu
24 grad in der lausitz am freitag kommt
ein kräftiger regen dauerregen sogar an
den alpen dann sinkt die
schneefallgrenze in den alpen auf 1000
meter und der sonntag schon wieder ein
bisschen milder bei 6 bis 17